I went on a cruise with the Impractical
Jokers these guys they're jokesters and
they're our friends and they have a
cruise and I went on there and and I was
in the hot tub right in the morning and
had a boy got in and this boy maybe 11
11 or 12 a thicker boy you know looked
like he was maybe from Nebraska or North
Texas you know thick kind of pasty you
know kind of nice kind of long hair
though a little numb in the eyes you
know a little polish you know kind of
like me I'm a little bit I mean I am
polish how polish Nicaraguan but I'm a
little numb in the eyes you know coming
in you know I'm coming in about 70 watt
and this boy was similar to that he was
seemed a little dull you know like they
hadn't fully like you like the like the
electrician hadn't visited his genetics
you know he was just a little bit dim
you know like maybe his
great-grandmother was as also his
great-great aunt you know where there
was some somebody not walked far to [ __ ]
at some point in his genetic history
there was maybe some light inbreeding or
just local seed that had been passed
between wombs somewhere along his
lineage but anyhow he's in the hot tub
and I'm in the hot tub this was early in
the morning you know I'd gone to the gym
early because my legs hurt and and I
don't like it when my legs hurt I like
my legs to feel regular like I like to
not feel them because that's the thing
if your legs hurt then they hurt but if
they're not hurting you just don't feel
your legs they're just there and you
don't feel them but um but anyhow I'm in
the hot tub and this fella he'd been in
a contest or something the day before
and he's wearing like a little bit of an
outfit he and I'm like a cape kind of
like a party cape you know just like a
and you know a cape like a huge bib kind
of it's on your back
for superhero [ __ ] and he was you know
he was and he had some I'm Sam I paint I
makeup or something by his eyes like
he'd been a dressed up the night before
at a costume type of deal and anyhow
this fella starts tickling me right
tickling me excuse me having some coffee
oh this boy starts tickling me and you
know I never really did like being
tickled dude in fact I told a girl that
I was hanging out with recently she goes
are you ticklish and I said if you
tickle me I will punch you in the
[ __ ] face because I've never enjoyed
it I don't like being forced into
painful laughter immediately I don't
like it
you know I like to have a little bit of
an inkling that I want to laugh and then
be laughing and not feeling that pain in
my body if somebody trying to jolt me or
just kind of trying to get into your
spirit you know and you just you just I
don't like it I feel I don't know it
just seems like something and see I
don't know uh some people I would like
to take I'll love to tickle the Chinese
man think about it think about the
Chinese right now literally visualize
them in your head
now think about tickling them dude think
about tickling them how cool is that
cuz they're active man and they're gonna
be fired up and and now okay now think
about tickling a Japanese person kind of
cuter you know cuter well you know
Chinese I know
Chinese be more aggressive and and know
that Chinese will strike the Chinese
will strike dude if you haven't spent
much time on the Chinese they will
strike bro they are oh they are they're
just like termites in a way and I don't
mean that in a negative connotation so
it'll take that out I just mean it in
they are
recive and they get it done and they'll
eat anything and they keep going and and
you wouldn't be surprised to find them
in the wood in your house dude
Chinese are plentiful I'll say that and
so this boy is tickling me right and he
starts tickling me and I don't know him
first of all I understand tickling
people you know you know people do that
tickling somebody you don't know uh [ __ ]
no brah you know that's way too much man
way too aggressive and so this fellow
was tickling me and I'm trying to keep
him off of me right and he had kind of
you know that paste he sort of
rubenesque kind of skin you know kind of
thick kind of I had some kid titties on
him you know what I'm talking about and
so I'm trying to push him off but not
push him because when I was touch him I
realized I'm leaving handprints on his
chest so this boy I'm trying to fend him
off and he's coming at me you know and
he's coming at me bro and he's tickling
and he's then he had one of his feet up
even he was flexible under the water
above the water he looked unflexible he
looked like a dam just like a piece of
[ __ ] white furniture you know
something you'd see in Sweden or
something that like a damn castle like a
Disney Castle he looked like a piece of
damn he looked like a [ __ ] a little
marshmallow loveseat you know but under
the water
agile and just just like a dam just like
a damn eel or a Gryphon you know and he
just and he brought one of his legs up
and was tickling me as well with his leg
right so this boy has both hands one leg
up tickling me
and I'm trying to keep him off me it's
just me and him in the hot tub it's 7:00
a.m. so people are kind of drinking
their coffee coming outside you know
bringing bowls of breakfast out pieces
of fruit and small you know small
breakfast plates and stuff like that
shareable plates you know small stuff
slices of um what else was it
grapefruits
and anyhow so me and him are set and
they start kind of looking over like
what's going on and I'm trying to push
this boy off of me and I'm starting to
leave these fingerprints and and because
he's hot the waters made him hot this is
a hot tub and I'm leaving imprints on
his chest and on his you know neck and
it's people are looking at us and then
the secured is a security guard you know
doing his rounds or whatever he can he
starts looking at us and act acting like
what's going on and I look and again I
don't know this boy okay imagine
somebody you don't know
now imagine that they are tickling you
in a hot tub while people are trying to
eat breakfast nearby dude what that's
not even normal that's not normal and
and I'm leaving marks on his body cuz
I'm pushing him off and now I'm kind of
fighting him you know kind of pushing
him under the water and he's a strong
boy he was strong felt like a damn like
it just like was just pinned against a
wall by like a Dodge Neon you know and
and the security guard comes over and
fun and is like what's going on he's on
his walkie-talkie and the security guard
on a ship on a cruise ship it's just the
bartender from the night before you know
but now he has a walkie-talkie you know
they just recycle everybody so I'm like
looking at the dude and he knew I'd been
drinking the night before so now I'll
probably look like a damn unsuccessful
PDF I'll you know so I just got out of
that deal I went back to sleep man
but you got to be careful on cruises
thank you guys for checking out this
clip and if you want to see another clip
then you can look at this clip or this
clip either one of these so did you pick
one or he's still just watching me do
this cuz this is alarming